now Jennifer you've been sent things by
fans were you in the theater and you got
a nice say no because you do get sent
quite odd things by fans I mean
generally drawings and nice things you
know gifts that they've sewn or made but
yes I did want to get sent some pubic
hair how was it arranged it was what I
was doing that did the first place years
ago must be 2530 years ago I was doing a
play in the West End and the trouble
with being in a theatre is everyone
knows where you are every night mm-hmm
you can't be anywhere else so they can
always drop things in and openings
envelope but I thought padded
[Laughter]
oh wow
[Applause]
say and and then a slightly odd sort of
cut-up little slightly pornographic
letter and of course you reported that
this was a guy who was doing it in the
West End - lots of actresses in lots of
plays and I think he got arrested after
he sent it to Felicity Kendal that's
trouble well maybe he just ran out of
pubic hair
[Applause]
[Music]
you